(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] "I believe in soulmates".
Strongly agree, strongly disagree?
Answer in the comments
below and suggest a prompt
on our Kickstarter.
- I have dealt with homophobic
people just like anyone else,
and there's a lot I can handle.
But what I can't handle
is seeing you hurt.
(tense music)
- [Announcer] "We were
pressured into getting married."
3, 2, 1, go.
- All right, so we're Mormon, like LDS
and there's a lot of pressure
in our church to get married.
Especially at our church
school that we went to,
everyone gets married really fast.
We got married after like five months
'cause we wanted to, and you
know, we loved each other.
But I feel like it
definitely, like there are
like some more like societal
pressures in that aspect.
So that's why I don't
like strongly disagree,
but I mostly disagree 'cause
I don't feel like we were.
- Yeah. I feel like we were
kind of not necessarily
pressured to get met married,
but more pressured to date for marriage.
But then once we met each
other and told our families
they were like, "Hey, maybe
you should slow down."
So we're more so pressured
not to get married, but.
- Yeah, I would say 0% pressure.
Like when I first saw
this woman, I was like,
"Ooh, I gotta get to know you girl."
And I honestly, we had both
been through broken homes
before, we both come
from divorced families.
And a big passion we have
is having a strong marriage.
And so I was just, I
never been more confident
about anything in my life than Amber J.
There was zero pressure. It
was all pressure on me like,
"I gotta hope she's feeling the same way.
'Cause I'm feeling you."
(laughing)
- And we actually dated for
less than a year as well.
But when you know, you know, right.
- [Announcer] I have some
hot takes submitted by
our audience. And so,
I'll read off the prompt
and you'll agree or
disagree with the prompt.
"Women do more work in marriages."
- I feel like no one should
be doing more work than the
other person in a marriage, personally.
I feel like in order
for a marriage to work
you have to come at it equally.
That might be just an idealistic
view, but I don't know.
- Yeah. I feel like, like
as a general statement, most
of the women I know, and
including the women who
have raised me, had a job.
They also took care of the kids
like most of the of time. Most
of the household chores also
fell on like, you know, on the woman.
And I do just see that more
often than not, that women
take on two jobs, literally
- [Announcer] "I have considered divorce."
- You know, we learned this
in a marriage class where
there's a rhino and a
hedgehog in every relationship
marriage. And so Charlie's
very much the rhino.
He's like, "Let's tackle this
now, we need to talk now."
And for me I'm a hedgehog,
I need to withdraw.
And so I think in those
moments, I don't know,
I think I'm more here.
It's just like, well, you know
when you're in the heat of the
moment, you know what I mean?
- Yeah, no, I definitely know
that our communication
styles are totally different.
We didn't communicate well at first.
I know Kenzie comes from a
divorced family and then saw
their family just fight and yell a lot.
I came from a family where my
parents had a disagreement,
they fought with passive
aggressive comments
and closed doors. So having
disagreements, having those
uncomfortable and hard
conversations, just wasn't easy
for me at all.
And so divorce sounds
a heck of a lot easier
than pushing through it,
which luckily we did.
We're doing great. We're happy now.
But there definitely
was a time where yeah,
it seems easier to just
drop everything and move on
instead of trying to grow.
- [Announcer] "I am happy
with how often we have sex."
- There's a hedgehog, there's a rhino,
then there's a rabbit.
I feel like I'm the
rabbit in this marriage.
And my expectations and my sex drive is,
my libido's very high, but
it's always been that high.
So we've, I came in honest,
it was on the table.
- I feel like sometimes, you
know, work and life get in the
way of that, responsibilities.
But I think, yeah (laughs),
we're tryna find a middle.
- You know, we're both here.
It'd be, you know, I think if
we had split and it would be
like evidence that we're not
talking about it (laughs).
But I think this is not a surprise to me.
I don't think it's a surprise
to you that we're both here
'cause it's something we talked about.
- I think, yeah. I think it's
like something we're working
through and it's just
like, when you get married
you get into like this routine.
You get into like just
working and going, you know?
And then at the end of the
day, you're just like, spent.
We're both like really
two ambitious people.
And I think like sometimes
it's the detriment
of the household sometimes, on both ends.
Not just you, but like, yeah.
- [Announcer] "I want
children." 3, 2, 1 go.
- If we could, we would've
had a baby yesterday.
- Yeah.
- But because we're same sex,
there's a lot of costs that go
behind making a baby.
So, we bought a house last
year and that was huge for us.
- Now kids are on the table
and that's another, you know
$40,000 that you're looking at per kid.
And if we want two, that's a
house and then some. 80,000.
- And as women, our clock is tickin'.
The older we get, the less
time we have to make it happen.
So for us it's a little different.
- So we actually have like
infertility struggles a lot.
We've had three miscarriages.
We actually just had one recently.
And so it's like, the topic of kids is
like super sensitive to us
'cause like we actually,
our miscarriage happened like last week.
And it was like really like
hard 'cause we were so excited,
we told our families, and we
were like so excited to like
announce to everyone at
Christmas and, sorry (cries).
It like breaks my heart
because like I know like it's
bringing us closer
together but it's like one
of the hardest things we've
had to go through together.
Because it's like, I know
Tyler's gonna be an amazing dad
but like I feel bad.
(stutters) I feel bad 'cause
I've told him before I'm like,
"It's fine if you like,
wanna go marry someone else
and have kids, 'cause I
know I can't provide that."
- Yeah, no it's been
really hard to deal with
just because like, it's not
the most I guess, accepting
topic to talk about.
I know a lot of people
feel very awkward whenever
that conversation does come up.
Like my parents have tried to help us out
but don't really know how.
- Like it kind of makes
me want to like be over
there sometimes where I'm just like,
"No, it's not worth it.
Like, the heartache and the
financial struggles.
It's just not worth it."
But at the end of the day, it's
like, I know it's worth it.
I know this is where I wanna be.
- [Announcer] "I don't
like my partner's family."
3, 2, 1, go.
- This is challenging (laughs)
- Speak your truth.
- I know, I know.
Um, I think there are
there are certain members
of your family that I absolutely adore.
- [Jay] It's okay.
- And I think there was a
time and place where I really
wanted to love your mom.
And then there's a time and
place where I just can't.
I have very thick skin,
I knew what I was like
signing up for. I've dealt
with like homophobic people,
just like anyone else, and
there's a lot I can handle.
But what I can't handle
is seeing you hurt.
And that's the hardest part
because like you're so amazing
and she's gonna miss out on so much.
- I mean, I totally understand
why you're standing there.
I wish you could stand here
with me, but I was raised
in a super homophobic
family and unfortunately
you can't really choose
who you're born into.
So I totally understand
your frustration, because I
carry that frustration
and I've carried that
throughout my whole life.
- I'm shocked you're there (laughs).
- No, I'm not. I think this
is a silver lining, right?
Like when I married
you, I gained a family.
And even though I might
disagree with certain points
of view in your family, overall
your family has been loving
from the moment I stepped into your life.
And I'm really appreciative of that
'cause I feel like I put a
lot of pressure on my friends
because they are my family.
But when I met you I feel like your family
filled in that hole.
- I think that's like the
beautiful thing about marriage
is that like you guys, you get
to set like a new precedent.
Like you get to set a new
like standard for your family.
And like that's what's
so beautiful about it.
Like you don't have to take on, you know,
what your family brought or
what your family gave to you.
This can make something new, so.
- [Announcer] "There are
things my partner doesn't know
about me." 3, 2, 1, go.
- For me it's like, I've had
like a lot of like hardships in
my life that's like, it
takes time to unlock,
you know what I mean? And like talk about.
And I feel like if I
was to like trauma-dump,
like you'd need therapy too.
- I mean, you did trauma-dump
on me like before we
met know though.
(group laughing)
We met on a dating app and her
first messages to me before
we were going on date she
was like, "By the way I went
through this, this, this, this,
this, this, and this within
the last like 12 months or so."
- I trauma-dumped on
you on our first date.
So I was like, "Okay, if she's
still here at the end of the
date, then obviously I have to marry you."
And like here we are.
And I think if there's
anything I don't know,
it's the new things that
we explore together.
Not necessarily super focused on the past,
like what you ate on your third birthday.
Like, probably don't know
that, but like, you know,
let's go explore
something new because like
this is, you're my future.
- [Announcer] "I'm with
my soulmate." 3, 2, 1, go.
- This is an interesting question.
I think I have like a disagreement
with the term soulmate.
Me being over here is not me
saying that you're not the
person that I'm supposed to be with.
It's just me saying that like,
I had so many opportunities
to do so many different things
and go down different roads
in my life, and I chose this one.
And then every day I'm
gonna have to continue
to choose this one.
- Yeah, I didn't know that's
what soulmate meant to you.
Yeah, first time hearing
you explain it that way.
I mean, for me like soulmate
is just someone you just
know you want in your life.
And when you and me got together
I was like, there was just
no fear, there was no, like
there was just nothing else.
Like I had no hesitation.
- Going back to the
beginning, we talked about
when you know, you know, and
so I feel like we did not meet
by accident. It was definitely
a divine orchestrated event
for us to cross paths, since
I grew up in LA and Charlie
grew up in Detroit, Michigan.
And so, it was for a reason.
Good marriages don't just happen, right?
It definitely does take
work, intentional time,
but I wouldn't wanna do
it with anyone else, so.
- Jay as lesbian you've
known, you've loved women from
like very beginning. I
identify as bisexual.
Before I met you I never
wanted to get married.
When I was with women maybe I wanted men.
When I was with men I wanted women.
It just felt like there was
always something missing.
And then I met you and
everything changed in my soul,
in my body and in my choices.
And so I used to not believe
in soulmates 'cause I felt
like, how can out of whatever
billion people in this world,
you just matched with one
and like the universe aligns?
It's just too much work for the universe,
like I feel sorry for it.
But when it works out, there's
just no other explanation
that so much inside of me can
change by meeting one person.
- [Announcer] That is a wrap.
(group clapping)
- [Jay] We did it, we survived.
(group cheering)
- We did it.
(group chatting and laughing)
- Good job. Good job.